[Music]
it's my pleasure to introduce a friend
Daniel : Ramos from our medical school
he was born and raised in Puerto Rico
somehow I ended up at Harvard after that
he's got to tell you how that happened
right guys bachelors went on and got a
PhD was that a Duke or
it was a Duke yet Duke and he did a
postdoc at Stanford and he's been here
since I think 2008 yep in our medical
school so he's got had a fascinating
career he's going to tell you all about
that and he's going to start science
that arees off this spring with a bank
Oh didn't work ha ha ha hopefully they
thought would be better all right thank
you
and I wanna begin by thanking Curt for
for the invitation and also giving a
hand of applause to all of the
volunteers and the body scientists that
are here serve on a on a called Saturday
morning learning about science so let me
tell you a little bit about what I like
to do today I like to tell you about how
we use C elegans which is a tiny worm
that we have taken a picture of here you
can see it here that's an embryo of C
elegans we put it like a question mark
how do we use it to understand how the
brain works how memories work now before
I start I'd like to mention that for the
parents if you're interested in these
topics or if you want to show your kids
more videos about about science or how
the wheel science I have a Twitter
account where I usually tweet about
these topics and also there are a number
of videos online where I've given a few
interviews in ibiology and we done
rather on these topics of basic research
but today what I like to do is I like to
tell you about first how I became a
scientist like what was it that brought
me to science and what scientists do so
as a
growing up in Puerto Rico I like science
but I didn't know any scientist so I
wasn't I wasn't really sure what
scientist II and I like to tell you
about what scientists do and how they do
it and then how we use a tiny one to
study something like a brain so how and
why and I'll end by giving some advice
to body in scientist or aspiring
scientist in the audience which I see a
lot of and there's gonna be one theme in
my talk that I'm gonna be coming back to
which is very important to how
scientists do our work which is that I
like to explain to you how we can use
small animals to ask big questions I'll
be coming back to that like how he said
that we can use a warrant to understand
something like a brain so like I like
Curt mentioned I was born and raised in
Puerto Rico and when I go back home and
when I leave kind of these circles of
scientists I'm frequently asked how do
you become a scientist and I like to
answer that question by saying that we
are all born scientists and I actually
am a scientist so I did an experiment to
test that I did an experiment to see if
we're actually all born scientists and
here are my results so these are these
are my experimental subjects I have
these are my daughter's when there were
babies I have triplets this is case Ani
Alexandra I'm Beatrice on their very
first trip to the beach in Puerto Rico
now they're actually there they're
actually doing an experiment themselves
they're learning this is the very first
time they have been on a beach so
they're the very first time they have
seen sand and you can see case Ani it's
kind of like going and grabbing the
suntan alexandra is breaking the sand
clumps in her fingers and well beatrice
is eating this and so they're actually
using their senses to understand how you
know what this new thing called sand is
and i'm gonna use this as an example of
how scientists learn because what
they're doing is not unlike what i do
every day
not that much but but what a lot of
exploration you see my senses so the
first concept i like to highlight is
that how we learn is context dependent
and what i mean by that is they're
learning about sand because there's
they're sitting on a beach if they were
not sitting on a beach they wouldn't
learning about Sun right so for example
here's another picture when there were
babies and here this is in New Haven in
the fall next to a bunch of leaves and
you can see now they're eating leaves
right so they are they're learning about
about what they have around them this is
important to how scientists learn we
learn depending on our context also we
learn from each other so in this
situation case Annie was in the middle
and Beatrice and Alexandra were in the
corner so she could and she couldn't
actually grab the leafs like her sisters
but she saw her sister scrub the leaves
and we're putting them in their mouth
and then spitting them out and in that
way she learned that leaves were not
edible okay and let me let me just make
an outside here and say look these are
experiments done by experts okay so kids
out there don't go and have triplets to
do these experiments okay this is only
only for scientists so so they so we
learn from each other we don't have to
go through the experience ourselves and
what we learn is widely applicable so
many years later and this is something
this is a proud achievement as a parent
they learn that none of these things are
edible here they are years later in a
pile of leaves and you can see they're
not eating leaves anymore so so this is
this is actually how we produce
knowledge how both humans and and and
human scientists how we actually
generate knowledge we societies don't do
something that different from what kids
do what we do is that we produce
knowledge by learning from each other by
learning dependent on context and then
by applying what we learned so what I
mean by applying what we learn is note
that they don't need to taste this ant
in every single [ __ ] that they go to to
know that scent is not edible once they
know sand is not edible they'll apply
that knowledge to every context ants
that's what scientists do to we generate
one set of concepts and then we apply
them widely and that's important to how
we generate knowledge and I like to
underscore here that because of these
concepts where scientists are from
matters because the context that were
from matters in inspiring the questions
that were interested on while the
knowledge that we generate is universal
what we learn and the context influences
what knowledge we're gonna generate and
I'd like to share with you how my
context being a puerto rican influence
my
interesting neuroscience and I like to
share that by sharing another story here
which is actually starts with this
beautiful video of baby sea turtles
being hatched in a beach in Puerto Rico
not far away from where I was born and
raised and I'd like you to notice two
things these turtles are just hatching
and they're all going in the same
direction actually they're going towards
the ocean they're beeline a net towards
the ocean so how how does a turtle know
that he needs to go to the ocean after
it comes out from the egg he has a bit
too turtle school how who totally turtle
he needs to go to the ocean
right so those are questions that I had
as a kid and there's something really
amazing that's happening here that's
invisible to us to our eyes but very
important which is that these animals
will remember this beach and I'll come
back to it to lay eggs on it so here I
like to underscore two things right
these turtles have a behavior from the
moment that they're born that they know
that they need to go to the ocean that's
a what we call a hardwired or innate
behavior it's an instinctual behavior
but they also have a memory that they're
forming about this place and they'll
come back to it and these behaviors are
actually underpinned they're formed by
the brain of these Turtles and a
question that you might have is how do
they know what to do and let me break
that down because this is actually
really incredible if you think about it
so here's the map of the world this is
what Puerto Rico is and some of these
leatherback turtles they're born like
babies over there and then they're gonna
grow up to be the size of a car they
grow up to be about nine feet long like
a Volkswagen and they'll travel the
world's oceans from that little island
of where I was also born it'll go
everywhere in the world and then when
they have to make the most important
decision in their lives which is where
they're gonna lay their eggs somehow in
a way that we don't understand they'll
find their way back not to the same not
only to the same island to the same
Beach that they were born so that is
actually pretty amazing right so if you
ask yourself how we said that this
animal can do that all I can say about
that is nobody knows the answer nobody
knows how this happens and I wanna I
wanna underscore that for a number of
reasons when I was the
of many of the kids that are here in the
audience today you know you go to school
and somebody ask you a question and then
they ask you a question and they give
you an answer and then they ask you a
question and then they give you another
answer and when you're a kid you get the
impression well all these questions have
answers and the only person that doesn't
know the answer is me but the truth is
that for most of the questions the most
interesting questions in nature we don't
have answers period and what scientists
do is we figure out what the answers are
that that's what our job is and there
are a lot of questions out there that
are unanswered and I'm gonna be
emphasizing some of them to see because
some may be some hits someone here
someone in this audience will actually
go on and answer some of those questions
so we do know some things right we do
know for example that the brain is
important for forming memory so the the
turtle's brain is important for it to
know where where he needs to come back
to and we know that one human brain this
is a human brain has about 100 billion
cells or neurons so how many people here
have heard about the world they were
neuron before show of hands
okay so neurons are the cells that make
up a brain and in each one of your brain
there are a hundred billion neurons so
how much is a hundred billion just to
give you an idea of how much how many
cells we're talking about let me make an
analogy there are more cells in your
brain than there are stars in the Milky
Way okay so when you when you stand like
when you go camping with your parents
and you're looking at the immensity of
the stars of the Milky Way and thinking
about the possibilities that are out
there think that your brain is a
reflection of the possibilities of the
galaxies you know that your brain is us
there ask many infinite possibilities in
your brain as their stars in the Milky
Way so look at it as a mirror of your
own of your own possibilities and the
the neurons that form the brain they
connect to each other here's a cartoon
diagram like a drawing of how these
neurons will look like you have the cell
body and then you have extensions of
these neurons and they're talking to
each other all the time and they talk to
each other through electrical signals
that's happening in
brain right now as I speak so when I'm
speaking my vocal cords are actually
creating sound waves that are moving
tiny hair cells in your ears and somehow
in a way that no one understands that is
creating thoughts and memories and
emotions in your own brain and what
neuroscientists do is we try to
understand how that process happens how
these neurons communicate with each
other and here are some of the most
interesting but unanswered questions in
neuroscience how he said that the brain
gets built during development so you
have a hundred billion neurons that have
to be connected to each other precisely
so that the brain can function how does
that happen how does the neuron know who
to connect to another question that we
don't know the answer to is what is a
memory so anyone here knows what a
memory is in the sense that you can you
know you can think right now of the face
of your mother or a loved one or your
best friend and an image comes to your
head right but no one can tell you how
what is that image what does it
represent how is it encoded in the cells
in the brain in the molecules that you
have in your brain and then importantly
what happens when the brain breaks down
how many how many people here in the
audience know of or have heard of people
that suffer of diseases like Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's and autism right so all
of those are diseases that are rooted in
the in the functioning of the brain and
some diseases like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's happen when some of these
circuits that that form our memories
start breaking down now it's gonna be
hard for science and for medicine to
figure out how diseases like Alzheimer's
work and how it results in losing
memories if we don't know what a memory
is right we don't know what we're
looking for how we're gonna find it so
as scientists what we do is we ask well
what what are these you know what are
these things and again I want to
underscore all of these questions they
don't have answers so when you go to
school maybe they'll ask you questions
that have answers maybe you'll do
experiments that they'll know a result
and you're supposed to get it right this
was I'm telling you they don't have
answers and the reason I Memphis
I think that is because maybe some some
of you will find the answer to it so
that's one of the things that I find
very stimulating as a scientist and when
I was a kid thinking wow I can I can use
my brain to contribute something that no
one has known before that's one of the
things that I find really exciting in
science so ok so I've been talking about
the brain and turtles and all these cool
things and this is the part of the talk
the awkward part of the talk that I have
to explain to you how how we do it and I
say the awkward part of the talk because
when I say what we do people are like
wait what how do you do what and so we
do it by using a tiny worm here's the
picture of the one that we use which is
called C elegans he said nematode it's
not that big okay it's about the size of
a coma in a sentence it's tiny it's
transparent it doesn't cause any disease
you can touch it with your fingers it
lives anywhere it doesn't have any
economic value so why wait is why are we
you seeing a worm to understand how a
brain works and people actually you know
some people get annoyed by that yeah
they like you telling me that you can
understand my brain by using a warm
brain how how does that work exactly
you just spend a bunch of time telling
us how how wonderful the brain is and so
here are some of the frequent questions
like how you can use a worm to
understand a human brain and why play
with worms and not work on something
more important like this is like you
know you're using a bunch of of money to
pay people to understand this once why
don't you go and work on something more
meaningful and okay so I get that
knowledge is cool but it's it really
useful like what are you in here you're
gonna build a worm robot like what are
you gonna do with this knowledge right
so to to explain that I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a detour here I'm gonna leave
let's leave the brain aside on the
warmer side for one second and I want to
explain to you how science works and I'm
gonna do it by using some historical
examples that I think are pretty cool
and I'm gonna ask some questions to the
audience still to engage you so I'm
gonna use some discoveries to explain
how science works and I'm gonna end up
explaining how and why we use worms but
to do that I'm gonna start with two
questions let's suppose that you have a
million dollars and somebody tells you
you can use that million
to understand and cure a disease like
like Alzheimer's or cancer or you can
use the million dollars to understand
the question like how you build a worm
essentially how you go from a single
cell to a full one honest question show
of hands how many people will use the
million dollars to cure get to do some
experiments where you think it will
result in a cure to cancer okay most of
you and that's reasonable how many
people will use the million dollars to
understand how a worm gets built a few
of you okay good so I'm gonna in the
next ten minutes I'm gonna ask you
another question like this and in the
next ten minutes if you pay attention
you're gonna understand why people can
do these experiments and contribute to
understanding how this is like cancers
and the early generation work here's my
second my my kind of like pg-13 part of
the talk kids you might want to cover
your ears how about theory exchange
genetic information how do they have sex
so to speak so how many people will want
to know the answer to that question
versus say built the most important
biopharmaceutical company that you can
build okay show hands who will use the 1
million dollars to build the most
powerful pharmaceutical company you can
build to develop new drugs okay who will
use the 1 million dollars to understand
this question ok let's see there are
very interesting very thoroughly so so
again I'm gonna explain and explain how
these discoveries led to one of the most
profound by a biopharmaceutical
discoveries that we have had so let's
start with this question how do you
build a worm ok so this is a pretty
fundamental question so in development
all of us every single person in this
audience started as a unicellular
organism at the moment of conception so
you have a sperm that that goes inside
an egg and then you have a single cell
and from that single cell you develop a
whole organism how people don't know but
a group of scientists about 25 years ago
decided they wanna they wanted to
examine that question that is very
interesting by using this warrant and
what they did is that they sat down and
they counted self they just looked at
these cells and they said okay from a
single cell you get to and from two you
get for them from four hundred eight and
so on and so forth and they kept track
of every single cell division as the
worm forms and they noticed some
patterns as they looked at different
animals they noticed that certain cells
which I'm going to represent here with
these balls certain cells always became
nerve cells the same cell in different
organism always became a nerve cell then
other cells always became muscles and
other cells always became God and this
led to a very important concept in
development called
cell fate these cells are destined or
fated to become nerve cells this ones
are destined or fated to become muscle
and this one's destined or failure to
become God and this opened up all sorts
of questions about what are these
signals what are the molecules what are
these structures that tell this cell
what is going to become so he can form
an organism but then they observed
something that didn't make sense
something that was weird what they
observed was that there were certain
cells that were always destined to die
and the reason this didn't make sense is
because people were thinking that the
way you get life is by by growing and
multiplying not by killing and dying so
why is it that certain cells are always
destined to die like as part of a
developmental program not because
they're sick not because they're damaged
they were destined to die the same way
that this cell is destined to become a
nerve cell so they started asking those
questions and then they realized that
the way that you grow an organism is not
only by dividing and multiplying which
is very important but also that death is
a very important part of life let me let
me give you an example to explain that
if you if you look at a dock at the
digits of a duck
they're webbed right they have tissue in
between them and if you look at the
digits of a chicken they don't the
reason that the digits of a chicken
don't have webs between them is because
well they need them to be able to carve
in the ground rather than swimming and
the webs in between those digits they
actually die
so that you can scoped out the digits of
the of the of the foot of the feet of
the chicken does that make sense
actually our own digits were not formed
by cells growing out like columns
instead our hands were kind of like that
and they were webbed when we were
embryos when we when we were fills us
but then all these cells in between died
and that's how we can have our digits so
a way of thinking about it is the same
way that in order to get shape out of a
block of marble this sculpture has to
like carve away pieces of of the of the
marble - to develop some shape when our
own organs and our own bodies are
forming cells need to die so this is
this is a pretty big discovery in
developmental biology it's a pretty big
one and then the scientist then went on
to identify the molecules that are the
signals that tell to the cells how to
die they realize they were really
important molecules that were essential
for normal development when those
molecules break if for example you have
a cell that's supposed to die and it
doesn't die that cell starts multiplying
abnormally and when he starts
multiplying on normally you end up with
tumors and when you end up with tumors
you can end up with problems like cancer
so the mechanisms that they figure out
in the worm are actually very important
for understanding cancer then if you
have cells that are not destined to die
but these molecules are always active
they're always there killing the cells
that are not supposed to die you end up
with problems like neural degeneration
because you're going to lose tissues
that you were not supposed to lose like
nerve cells so for these discoveries
that group won the Nobel Prize ok so
this is actually a pretty important a
pre important fundamental discovery now
you open the newspaper you will read
that there's a group of people that won
the Nobel Prize for discoveries that
they did on cancer and neural
degeneration but I want to remind you
that they were not looking at questions
of cancer and neural degeneration they
were looking at a fundamental question
in biology and the fundamental question
in biology that were asking was how do
you form a one
does that make sense this is very
important because this motivation of how
we said that you that they you start
with the question in biology you cannot
answer this big disease questions if you
don't understand how the fundamental
processes work right so so that's that's
one of the aspects that I like to
underscore here now let's go to this
example here of how bacteria have sex so
in this example how bacteria have sex
this this guy actually is a real-life
person is a scientist his name is herb
Boyer he worked a year as a postdoc and
herb Boyer became interested in how
bacteria exchange genetic information
and he discovered that one of the ways
in which bacteria exchange genetic
information is that they have proteins
that are able to cut DNA like they cut
you can cut DNA and there are other
proteins that can paste it and then he
had an idea he thought wait a second if
you can cut DNA from one organism and
paste it into another one can you trick
a cell from one organism to express a
protein from another organism so how
many people here are or know of other
people that are diabetic a lot of you ok
so until the nineties if you were a
diabetic patient the way your insulin
will come from pigs ok people will have
easily was harvested from pigs and Pig
insulin it was it came from pigs because
Pig insulin is very similar to human
insulin but it is not human insulin I
don't know if like the parents probably
remember this but there were all these
conversations about how if you get like
insulin from pigs are you bringing
retroviruses or other viruses also from
the pig into the patient right so herb
Boyer had an idea which was can we take
the gene that calls for insulin and use
the genetic tricks of corene and pasting
DNA and trick a bacterial cell to make
insulin and he did that and that
resulted in the birth of the
biotechnology industry so the specific
company that he started is called
Genentech but this is a 430 billion
industry right now now if you open a
newspaper you will read that the
scientists developed this for a hundred
four hundred thirty billion dollar
industry by developing insulin to
treat diabetes and you will think that
that's how he started thinking about it
but I want to remind you that the
equation that he started with wasn't how
do you treat diabetic diabetes it was
how he said that bacteria have sex now
these two examples are arguably
extraordinary because they have
extraordinary results but they're not
extraordinary in the process because
this is how science actually works this
is how scientists actually develop their
own ideas they start with curiosity
based research and then they build that
up to these to these discoveries right
so I for those I mean for all of you
that live in New Haven or Boyer donated
a building that's gonna live or Center
which many of you have probably seen in
Congress Avenue so I'll finish with one
last story and then I'll go back to how
we used he wants to to study how the
nervous system works so how many people
here remember superstorm sandy maybe
many of the kids were were young when
you remember it do you guys remember
that there was an old oak that fell in
the New Haven Green did anybody remember
that or was that lost in the losing
power and all that so there's this hope
that was planted in the New Haven green
like a hundred and some years ago back
like I think in the in the 1900s when
this oak comes down in its root what do
they find do you guys see this here
that's a human skeleton you can see you
can see the teeth here the ice will be
around here this is the back part of the
skull
here's the ribcage you see it okay how
many people here knew that the New Haven
green was actually a cemetery okay so
the New Haven Green is a cemetery and
when you're actually standing in your
hair and green you actually stand anyone
used to be a cemetery there are a lot of
corpses right underneath you there and
these three had its roots around well
used to be a common grave and he was a
common grief that was built in the
eighteen hundreds because there was an
epidemic of yellow fever in New Haven
and there were so many people dying of
yellow fever how many people here have
had yellow fever nobody okay there's a
reason for that
which I'll explain but back then people
were dropping like flies that word that
word up there were so many people were
dying they had to build a common grave
for yellow for the people that were
dying and this is one of the unfortunate
people that lost their life in that
epidemic of yellow fever so I wrote an
article about this and this happened
okay this happened the day of Halloween
I don't know if people remember that but
it was the day of Halloween that this
tree falls down and skeleton comes off
like so this past Halloween a century
old human skeleton resurfaced in the New
Haven Green in Connecticut after
superstorm sandy it reminded everyone
that what is today a series Central Park
was once the town cemetery it also
reminded some of us that early in an
earlier time in New England life
expectancy was about 40 years do people
know what life expectancy how many
people know how life expectancy is the
average number of years that you are
expected to live when you're born it
doesn't mean that everyone died around
when they were like 40 years old it just
means that a lot of people die young
because they we didn't have the medical
advances that we have right now so life
expectancy in New England when this
person that was about 40 years now it's
78 years okay so what happened between
then and now and let me let me start by
saying that that between the Stone Age
and the 1900s for 40,000 years of human
history
life expectancy did not change since
Adam he 40,000 so there were empires
that came up when people build it Eiffel
Tower the Great Wall of China life
expectancy worldwide did not change for
40,000 years and then and he was allowed
in the world he was about thirty years
of age in the in the u.s. he was 40 but
in the world he was 30 so and right now
the world life expectancy is 72 it
doubled so what happened what happened
at that time so if you look back at Mary
seen a Western medicine at that time the
main thought the weather people thought
our medicine was that we had this
different humors that controlled who we
were and I'm not gonna go into details a
lot about how that worked but let me
just tell you that that's not how the
human body works okay and and the reason
this is a good example that I like to
use this is George Washington in his
deathbed
so how many people here know what George
Washington dialogue
few people what what what what do you
guys think George Washington died off
yeah yes very good he died of a throat
infection he was 68 I think 60 something
like that and he died of a throat
infection but actually the cost of death
like which I mean with they have
autopsies back then but people think
that the cause of death wasn't infection
itself
he was bled five times they took over
five liters of blood out of his body to
cure the infection why would you take
five liters of blood out of a human
being to cure an infection well how do
we treat you how do we treat infections
today
exactly so that back then they thought
that there was bad blood and for for you
to cure an infection you needed to get
rid of the bad blood that's exactly
right that's what they thought about
them that's not how it works what if you
have an infection today how do you cure
it under you know antibiotics that's
right so why can't they use antibiotics
back then they didn't know they didn't
even know that bacteria cause this is
right so so actually doctors back then
have people seen this this this image
have some of you seen this image
whatwhat is this what's that that's that
was that's an image of the plague but
this character here who will wear that
mask a doctor this is this is a doctor
is now a symbol of death and the plague
but this was a doctor and you know why
the word unmask excellent so they will
wear this mask so they could put a bunch
of herbs there to block away the bad air
malaria malaria the disease it's called
malaria because in Italian it means bad
air and the reason is because they had
no idea that he was caused by a parasite
all that it was transmitted by
mosquitoes all they thought was there's
bad air so I'm gonna block my D now that
doesn't work because that's not the root
cause of the disease right so how is it
that humanity ended up advancing life
expectancy discovery microbes and things
like that and it was through basic
research so what change what change was
that there were curious people like this
guy here this is LuAnn hook could
develop the first microscopes and then
they discovered wait a second what I see
is not all there is what I see it's just
a fraction of what's going on and
there's a whole universe of microscopic
organisms out there that I cannot see
with my with my naked eyes I need
microscopes to be able to see them and
then after he made that discovery of of
microscopes and microbes there were
people like pastor that made discoveries
of sterilization and later Alexander
Fleming who made the discovery of
antibiotics
it was mentioned here right so but let
me let me underscore this if we don't
know about microbes you know how we cure
this is we believe you to death so with
that I like to underscore that even
Western medicine that we're so proud of
without science is little more than
witchcraft
okay actually can do more harm than good
if we don't know actually how to how to
what is going on so this is the end of
my detour I'm gonna come back to the
brain and answer this question why do we
use an animal like this to study the
brain well part of it is curiosity
driven research we're just interested in
how it works the same way that the
people that made the discoveries that
were very important for cancer and neuro
degeneration made the discoveries by
looking about how a worm forms so we're
interested in how does this animal think
the other part is that nature when it
comes up with a solution to a problem it
uses us over and over again so the
nervous system that makes this animal
think and behave if you look at the
building blocks of that nervous system
is not unlike the building blocks of our
own nervous system yet we don't
understand how it works so we think that
if we can understand that in this
organism we can understand that in our
own nervous system in our own minds and
how it breaks down in disease and the
last part which I raised earlier when I
was showing the picture of my kids is
that what we learn we can apply it
widely so what we learned is in this
organism the fundamental aspects we can
then apply to other things well one of
the really cool things that we can do in
this animal is that we can actually
because it's transparent we can label it
like a Christmas tree we can look at all
the different cells that form part of
the animal here's the head and the brain
and the different neurons that form that
format and then we have we can make
images like this this is actually a
picture taken by my friend mark hammer
loan who's also a professor here and
look how beautiful he can label this
this animal he can actually label the
neurons that make a neurotransmitter
called acetylcholine in red and another
another set of neurons that labeled one
that makes gaba in green and you know it
looks it's actually looks gorgeous to me
right but the important thing is we can
see single cells so how how do we do
this how can we do this and the way that
we can do this I want to explain again
how we make discoveries is because
a few years back scientists a different
group of scientists that don't study the
brain at all had also a curiosity driven
question which was how we said that this
jellyfish which is called acquire a
Victoria how is a Derek globe that was a
question they didn't want a cure a
disease they didn't had they have like
because period just how is it that this
animal emits beautiful fluorescent light
and by stolen how it did it they ended
up discovering this Japanese scientist
Osamu Shimomura and their of discovery
in a protein that is important for this
animal to fluoresce which is called
green fluorescent protein because if
fluorescence in green and then this
other scientist at Columbia University
Martin Chalfie put it inside worms and
he could actually see with this
fluorescent protein this structure of
the whole nervous system and then there
was a third scientist Roger Shan who
then took atom modified to make it all
sorts of different colors red yellow
blue green etc naturally now we have all
these different variants GFP which is
green fluorescent protein yfp which is
yellow fluorescent protein and M sherry
which guess what color it is right is
red right so and this is actually a
picture that was done with bacteria so
this is a bacterial plate and you have
different bacteria that are expressing
these different proteins and they have
actually plated them in different ways
to make this this image but these are
all bacterial color isn't that amazing
so and then but importantly you can
label single cells in the in the
nematode in the animal clas so this is
how we can actually generate these this
type of image we can use fluorescent
proteins we put them inside the animal
and then we can see these cells and what
is the importance of seeing these cells
well because we can see single cells
with these fluorescent proteins with
microscopes that that my lab had
developed with other collaborators and
here I'm putting pictures of
collaborators because when I was when I
was a kid I had the impression that
science was this very lonely process of
like thinking and and coming up with
ideas and nothing farther from the truth
it's actually a ton of fun you get to
work with some of your best friends and
it's it's actually it's it's it's it's
it's fantastic
and
I get to meet friends and get together
and think about how to answer questions
and one of the ideas that we had was to
build this microscope which allows us to
take movies I did when I'm going to show
you here where we put a fluorescent
protein inside an embryo and we can see
the brain forming so this would be very
first cell stuff on my brain in a C
elegans embryo you can see them growing
out and forming a ring there and now the
animal starts moving and all these other
cells join and now this is the beginning
of the brain of the animal and I'm
showing you this accelerated but we can
actually go frame by frame of the movie
and cannot make up this story of how we
said that these cells are coordinating
are talking to each other to be able to
build a brain which is one of the
important questions that I told you at
the beginning that lacks an answer right
if you're interested in this and you
want to see like ooh movies there's some
ibioseminars in which I have explained
this in more detail but for the purposes
of now I just want to mention we can see
the development of the nervous system of
the animals are growing and the other
thing I want to come back to the turtle
that we can do is that the turtles you
know I told you that they grow pretty
big about the size of a Volkswagen and
then they will come back to the beach in
which they were born and I'll remember
that [ __ ] and we don't know how that
happens and nematodes well they don't
they don't travel the world and go to
different beaches but they also form
memories they also remember things let
me show you one of them
so the nematodes unlike us they don't
have an innate preferred temperature so
humans we always like the same
temperature even people that say oh I
like the cold they don't like the cold I
mean they they like to be in the cold
with a lot of jackets on top of them but
we need to have the same temperature
about 37 degrees Celsius as humans the
warmth not so much between 15 degrees
Celsius and 25 degrees Celsius they
don't they don't care that much what
temperature they're at but they remember
if they were in a pleasant condition at
that temperature for example what the
worms like this worms they like to eat
bacteria so if you take a worm and you
feel it at 15 degree Celsius and then
you put them in a temperature gradient
that animal will remember that
temperature and come back to that
temperature when you put them in in an
integrated look at this so these are
this is a gradient here
these are a lot of little ones that
we're putting we train them to lightly
cold temperature or what are they all
doing they're moving towards the cold
temperature okay now we can take these
same animals and retrain them it takes
about four hours for them to learn the
new temperature and we if we put them
now at 25 degrees look at what they do
now they all move to the warm
temperature here I colored them blue and
red to represent the experience that
they had but these animals are identical
to it these are the same animals the
only difference between these animals
and these animals is the previous
experience so you can see that they can
learn a temperature that they like and
then so we can represent them like this
you know the ones that were grown in the
cold they go to the cold the ones that
were born running the ones they go to
the warmth and then we can ask well what
change in their brain what change here
and here that these animals now remember
different temperatures what is a
temperature like what is a temperature
in the brain of an animal right so
that's the question that we had and then
we have developed ways of this this is a
move in a Miss if it plays okay so here
you can see a warm and it's moving and
we're tracking it this is assuming you
will see in a single cell in the brain
of the animal and we're tracking how
that cell is changing activity
essentially how the electricity is
changing through that cell as this
animal is performing the behavior of
thermo taxes and there's a lot of
complex information here so let me let
me boil it down in this in this
experiment I want to show you so just to
show you the kind of experiments that we
can do we can look at single cells in
the brain of live animals by using these
fluorescent markers from jellyfish right
that I told you about we can build
microscopes when we can change the
temperature very precisely and then here
I'm gonna use this as a placeholder to
explain the experiment and then I'm
gonna show you the result so what we do
is that we're given at a temperature
ramp we're going warmer and warmer and
warmer can if in oscillations and this
line here represents the temperature or
which the animal was in the experiment
the result is gonna be here and what
you're gonna see is austrack in a single
neuron this is the cell body this is the
axon and the dendrite that it uses to
feel the temperature and let's see what
the animal does
that's the cell body the animal is alive
so it's moving nothing is happening then
it hits the temperature that the animal
was seen and it's almost like a
sing-along let's see that like every
time the temperature increases this
increases in fluorescence let's look at
it again nothing is happening not only
hits this point here which is the
temperature that the animal was that
there boom boom you can see the nose
moving here boom because the animal is
alive
so what this tells us is it's a few
things but I'm gonna ask the kids in the
audience to see if they can if they can
help interpret this result so first
question what does it tell us about this
red line here so what happens over here
is the animal responding or not
responding not responding ok so it tells
us that the responses really start at
the temperature that the animal that the
animal was before the experiment what is
another experiment you'll like to do is
that is that is that a fixed thing is
that always the same for the same thing
for the temperature or can can you
change that right at that that's a
question I'd like to know I like to
repeat this experiment and change the
temperature that the animal was at and
see if I can change this threshold you
move it up or down does that make sense
to people
right okay so we did that experiment and
it turns out that this temperature that
the animals start responding to it
changes dependent on the experience that
the animal had before ok so then what
does it tell you about the responses
over here so what is the animal
responding to what is this cell
responding to hear it responding to
warming above this temperature so what
this neuron is essentially doing is
telling the animal you are warmer right
now you're moving to a warmer
temperature than you were before but but
that that temperature this one it it
changes as the animal is navigating the
gradient so now doing this type of
experiments with a jellyfish protein in
a nematode we can start understanding
how memory works because we can start
piecing together the puzzle of how this
animal can conceptualize an abstract
concept like temperature what is
temperature for an arm right the neuron
is not a thermometer
how does he know how to interpret
temperature and to pass it on to the
other circuits of the brain
and to tell the animal which territory
to go to so we can start doing those
type of experiments with this does that
make sense any questions about that yes
as you're approaching the temperature
until you hit the temperature once it
crosses the threshold I might expect it
to respond negatively so that it could
go back to the temperature so that's a
great question so what happens when you
don't have information here right so how
does the animal know when it's going
colder like I told you how the animal
knows when it's going warmer so this
this gets to an important point of
science which is that with this sensor
we can see how the animal is responding
to the ones but we cannot see when the
animal is not responding right there's
some things we cannot say with these
sensors we cannot see
other cells we cannot see these other
responses but what we can do is that we
can measure electricity we have ways of
measuring electricity in that neuron and
we know that when the animals are going
colder actually this neuron what it does
is that it it instead of communicating
more electricity it reduces its capacity
to communicate electricity so there's
information there that we're not
actually capturing in this experiment
does that make sense so the important
concept for the for for all the body
scientists out there is that some
experiments will give you some
information but no experiment gives you
all of the information so you always
have to you have to supplement with
different experiments to be able to to
learn that any other questions I think
it's okay so so other things that we can
do in my lab is for example we can watch
what I call the dance of the molecular
machines that produce energies I'm going
to show you here this is a cell that
that has a hearing green we have
molecular machines labeled that are
known to produce energy and this is a
video where we can make the animal
energetically stress and we're going to
see that they're going to start forming
these here they start forming these
clusters and then we relax the energy so
now we have they have energy they go
away we energetically stress them they
form them again we date that we reduce
it and they go away so let me let me
play that again and explain it explain
what we're looking at oh here we go okay
so what we're doing here is
that we are telling the animal you have
we're giving the neuron a stimuli in
which we energetically stress it and
then we see this machine that it makes
energy when we energetically stress
dinner and we see this machine that
makes energy form and respond by making
more energy so we are actually we are
controlling a dance of molecules inside
this cell that come together they
cooperate to make this this this energy
machine so right now the neuron is in
normal conditions it has no reason to
make these machines sometimes some of
them are formed here but in many places
there they're not they're not actually
formed and then when we put them on
their energy stress so now we're telling
that you have to make this machine if
you want to have energy the machine this
machine self-assembles and boom now you
can see it these dots represent a
machine forming even in these areas
where the machine was kind of there you
can see that it becomes tighter and it
becomes tighter because the machine is
forming when we remove the energy stress
now the neuron doesn't have to form
these machines the Machine dissolves it
doesn't form anymore then we we induce
the energy stress they form again so
doing this type of experiments we can
see how the the molecular machines
inside these cells are actually
responding to even the animals thinking
needing energy for thought processes and
things like that like how are they
responding to to to be able to create
thoughts and experiences sensory
experiences in the animal and I I'm
gonna finish by saying what we have
learned on and I'm gonna move to the
last part which is just some advice for
the body scientists so what have we
learned so far we learned how neurons
find each other and how they connect
using the microscopes that I show you we
have learned how their hands maintain
the connections during growth we have
learned how they modify their
connections to in learning and how they
keep them healthy and working well and I
want to emphasize that I don't have time
to give like a full fresh research talk
here but I want to mention that the
mechanisms that we have discovered
including the ones that I show you today
in terms of how these energy machines
come together these mechanisms are
actually also present in our own neurons
so we're learning from them
mental aspects of biology by using these
tiny worms that are relevant to her how
our own brains work and then we have
colleagues we have friends that can go
to other systems vertebrate systems even
human cells and test if what we're
discovering is actually important to how
our own cells work but more important
than what we have learned are the
questions that remain unanswered right I
think a scientist that's what we do we
think of all questions that remain
unanswered I just want to emphasize that
I want to finish here with the with my
kids again this is I they're like
picking up sea slugs in the empty Beach
and the the way that scientists learn is
by the same way that everyone else
learns which is by asking questions so
the main advice that I have for all the
body scientists out there is you know
this is how we make advancements in
science through curiosity driven
research and my main advice to the body
scientist is don't stop asking questions
doesn't matter if you're 8 years old or
80 years old when you stop asking
questions you stop learning so if the
world out there makes sense to you
you're not asking enough questions
because most of the things out there
they they just we don't understand them
they don't make sense yet maybe they're
waiting for you to make a discovery so
don't stop asking questions
stay curious and with that I'd like to
finish by showing the picture of the
people that did the work this is my lab
they come from all parts of the world so
this is one of the most exciting aspects
of being a scientist I mentioned I'm
from Puerto Rico so Joe is from China
saris from Pennsylvania Shivani is from
from Suriname sorry her family's from
Korea Assisi is from China hosting is
from Spain Tita she's from India Noelle
is from rural Pennsylvania Ian is from
Texas Josh here it leads to many parts
but he's originally from rural Georgia
Jun is from Korea
richard is from Kerala Lanie's from also
from China Leighton is from originally
born in Jamaica wanna raised here in
Connecticut
mark is from Utah and Ernesto is also
from Puerto Rico and I've had people
that that have come from five different
continents like over 15 different
countries and one of the most wonderful
things about science is that this is
this is actually a it's like it's a
human instinct curiosity is a human
instinct that we are all humans share
and it's a wonderful way of actually
connecting with people from other
cultures and other parts of the world to
find answers to questions that all
humans wonder about with that I'll
finish and I'd like to take any
questions you might have
thank you
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
so how whether some bacteria have to
have cells so bacterias are actually
single cells they're unicellular
organisms in our case on live bacteria
we have like billions of cells and in
our brain we have a hundred billion on
that icon neurons so there's a big
there's a difference between the
bacteria and us in that the bacteria
only has a single cell
yeah the bacteria has some inside that
single cell there are a lot of machines
that make the bacteria work we have all
of those machines that the bacteria has
plus we have billions of neurons to
another at the same time thank you for
that question
any other questions yes
right it's a great question so how he
said that for 40 thousand years of in my
history the lifespan of of life
expectancy of humans essentially has
changed and then in the last 100 years
it has more than doubled and the reason
is because in the last 120 years in
Western medicine we have had fundamental
discoveries like for example microbes so
if you don't know about microbes you are
not going to look for antibiotics and if
you don't look for antibiotics then
you're not going to be able to cure
infections
so you met you you you answer the
question right that Washington died of
of a throat infection and before if you
will have an infection you have that
things like scarlet fever you know you
can read all books and they talk about
these people having scarlet fever how
many people here have had scarlet fever
nobody because kind of fever is not a
thing anymore because you can take
antibiotics before if you got an
infection that would be really scary
actually most people in world died of
infections so but that's that's
unimportant an important lesson for all
of us there people have wanted to cure
diseases for thousands of years but if
we don't understand the root causes if
we don't understand the concepts like
microbes we cannot cure it we might want
to cure Alzheimer's but if we don't
understand how memories form or Houston
Aeros function how we gonna cure it our
aspiration is not enough to take us to
the goal line and then if you look at
the history of science the way that
those fundamental discoveries that we
need to make advances in medicine or in
technology happen is through curiosity
driven research I like to I'm gonna
share one more story like everyone sees
this Sun going around the earth right
every everyone sees that every day you
see this song going around the earth so
for most of humanity people thought well
the earth is the center of the world of
the universe because you can see I see
it with my eyes this song going around
the earth but what did scientists do
like a scientist called Copernicus he
slowed down he said wait I see it but
it's what I'm saying the truth is this
song really going around the earth
or II see that from my perspective he
looks like this one is going around the
earth on it's really all that are moving
around the Sun and he used science to
examine what but most people were
thinking to be truth to examine and show
that he was false that is actually also
moving around the Sun and not the Sun
moving around the earth and that's what
scientists do we ask questions when
other people are stopped asking
questions we keep on asking questions
and then we examine our assumptions and
that's how we can double life expectancy
we can we can when when other people are
putting masks like this with a bunch of
perfumes scientists are like wait a
second is it really bad area right
that's a great question one of my my my
best friends is here in the audience and
that's exactly what you stole is
valentina greco she studies how he said
that cells decide what they're gonna
become and it's a very active area of
research right now like what he said
like what is it that tells a cell to
become a neuron that's that's an
unanswered question in the animal that I
use the the programs that tell cells to
become a god cell or a neuron or a skin
cell are similar to the programs in our
own cells but one big difference is that
very flexible so in in DC elegans in the
nematode those cells are they don't have
a lot of flexibility they don't they
don't come out and say well what is the
environment what do I become but in our
own in our own ourselves the environment
actually plays a very important role as
one of the the discoveries that my
friend have made and her colleagues is
that the environment makes plays an
important role in telling this cell what
is supposed to become so these cells
have more flexibility but in all animals
there are programs that tell the cell
what to become and some of those
programs tell it today great questions
any other questions we ever done stop
asking questions
so my questions to that you know some
curious scientists in your enemy and we
seem to be
oh no I think how do you keep asking
questions and I think III think that one
of the reasons I kept asking questions
was because my parents didn't make me
feel awkward for asking questions sorry
so they they encouraged me asking
questions and also they felt comfortable
saying I don't know and I think it's
important to recognize that a lot of the
questions that that you the kids in the
audience might ask we might not know the
answer and that is that is that is good
that's not a bad thing it's good to
recognize what you don't know that's
actually one of the big jobs that I have
as a scientist is to differentiate what
I know from what I don't really know and
so just keep on asking questions until
the person says I don't know and if they
get annoyed by you asking questions
that's their problem not yours
so you should keep on asking questions
dun dun don't don't be shy because when
you stop asking questions you'll stop
learning
and so so you might think you wanted a
scientist goes huh that was unexpected
that's interesting so so the question is
how the brain cells form that's a great
question how do bracers form in the
beginning before they're destined to be
brain cells and the the thing to
understand about that is that at the
moment when every living being in planet
Earth started like each of us for
example at the moment when our life
started we were single cells we were and
that single cell divided a bunch of
times to form the the D cells that will
then decide I'm gonna become a nerve
cell or I'm gonna become a god cell and
and things like that so that so the so
we all these cells come from these one
cell that's capable of becoming many
things and and that one cell then there
are a number of divisions were the
different daughters all specialized it
become a specific tissue but what are
the instructions by which that happens
people don't understand yet and and and
the reason I keep on saying what people
don't understand is because when I was a
kid and I went to cook the classroom
they will always tell me what people
understood but they never told me what
people didn't understand so I got the
impression that all these questions are
answers and that when I didn't know the
answer it was because I didn't know the
answer and not because somebody else did
know the answer now that I'm a scientist
I realized the opposite most questions
people don't know the answer and only
the few questions that people know the
answers are the ones that are telling
school so it's important to know that
because if you want to be a scientist
you might get the impression well what
am I gonna discover everything is
discovered and that's not true I see a
question about in the back over there
why sand yeah what is in the middle of
the Milky Way and I
yeah so what is in the middle of the
galaxy
we uh we don't know we don't know what's
in the middle of the galaxy that yeah
the Milky Way we don't know either we we
just like actually in the history of
humanity in the scientific history of
humanity it was only recently so to
speak that we discover that we're not
going that the Sun is not going around
the earth that we are going around the
Sun so there are a lot of questions out
there that we don't know the answer to
and that is exciting
voilá how many cells multiply each day
that that is that is a great question
for which I don't know the answer and I
think probably some scientists will have
estimated it but I bet you no one has
actually gone in and counted every cell
that dies or multiplies each day but I
will I will guess there millions of
cells because only in the only in the
inner God and in our skin cells would
constantly constantly share it cells
like when you get wounded for example
new cells form like if you get scraped
like by falling from the bike new cells
form and replace them and I just
represents the fact that our skin cells
are constantly replenishing themselves
[Applause]
[Music]